eric is laughing about something and i
don't know what he's laughing about
what have you seen you haven't seen this
what is it oh my god look at this it's
like an invisible step
it's a cheerleader right yeah i can't do
that well there's something there
there's definitely something there
there's something i don't there's
definitely something there wait keep
going
that one wasn't as good so we just uh
saw the invisible box challenge
it's not real i don't know i think it
was real i think i can do it
eric you cannot do that i feel like i
could definitely do it so we're gonna
try to do it
if it's even real still preparing my
hair oh okay sorry
okay cause people fake viral stuff all
the time remember that that girl who
like
put herself on fire yeah yeah exactly it
could be fake i'm an optimist
i think this was real i think i'll be
able to learn
[Music]
i just farted out of my mouth you see it
let's first see if other people can do
it yeah want to see if sarah can do it
jay can you do let's find out jay can
you do it
[Music]
this looks like an important meeting
yeah invisible step can you do it
my heart says yes all right that's a
high step
no no you can't just lower a step you
have to throw out that step and bring in
a new one
out of here there we go and let's put in
this lower step
i'm just gonna go crying the bathroom
can you do this
not not now but i will be able to danny
are you recording right now
i have five seconds five seconds five
seconds that's enough i'm an old man
all right that one that was not even
about
that's a curve i actually have to leave
and do my job
i think it was like photoshop magic or
something photoshop i think it was i
don't believe
green screen it was like too fluid all
right
i told you i can't do it without having
to see
it it's what have we learned nobody at
buzzfeed can do the invisible box
challenge
so eric and i are gonna go ask the
people of new york
whether they can do the invisible step
eric you can't film and just keep doing
it
i'm gonna try
i think we can find people who can do it
better than i can at least right the
invisible step
the invisible stuff i know do you know
what that is this is the video so it's
like you pretend there's an invisible
step there
and then you step over it what are your
thoughts because she stood on something
you think there was something there
something had to be there that's not the
step
but he just went up on it the people who
can do it make it look like super easy
he's a cheater he's a phoning so the
viral video there's a fake step there
he's a faker
i've seen the video i thought it was
like chopped out but it wasn't because
like people are doing it
now do like the tap tap that you have
the step there
[Music]
your foot is going through the step
okay go for it don't make it weird i
know
you went through the step invisible step
is here
you go like here and then
you can probably do so much no i'm not
good at it yet i still have to practice
is the invisible step real i believe it
is she's not a witch i'm no
no she's not step on my hand and i'll
help you
better that's better you want to try it
try it
i believe in you come on make your
friends proud
guys i'm proud of you guys just keep
practicing you do that like 100 more
times
and i've got it we tried everyone at
buzzfeed and then
everyone in new york no one could really
do the invisible box challenge so
now we're gonna go straight to the
source hey ariel
it's a camera trick right no i told you
it's definitely real
it's 100 it's 100 how long did it take
you to learn this
about two minutes they're like ariel
yours is actually pretty good and um i
was like oh record it then the third
time was that video that everyone that's
viral do you want to show them what show
what you got right now
uh yeah sure
okay not bad not bad keep that leg that
stays stationary
up for a longer time you are the master
and we really
look up to you we respect you even if it
is witchcraft
um i i have no problem with that uh we
applaud you
i talk to the you know the professional
i know what i need to do i'm gonna go
train i'm gonna get it down
[Music]
eric steps there's steps right here
is he okay so while eric's
training to get this down i'm going to
do my own
training and i'm going to go visit the
green screen
i feel like i'm starting to really
understand what a step is
[Music]
i can't do it my box is ready
[Music]
ah look at that
[Music]
not to move this leg at all
[Applause]
oh my god
that was honestly incredible like i had
so much support
okay they just left after like a second
i think i got it down so all i have left
to do is
show my invisible step to the best
invisible stepper
all right so let's call her back yeah
there you go really yeah you did it
you accomplished it i don't even know
what to say can you tweet me out
i will hey eric did you see my um
instagram i don't think i follow you
eric that's tell me my instagram bro
no it's not that's not underrated sarah
is that you
[Music]
no no that's not real is that you
yeah that's me what how did you do that
no that's that's a green screen that's a
green screen
so while you were training that's what i
was doing did it go viral
i mean it has 300 views on instagram so
while i didn't like physically do it i
technically did it so i'm feeling good
about myself
eric how you feeling eric
wait where'd eric go
you